mother in sunday celebrated for over a
century a time when millions of cards
are sent and bouquets delivered to our
mums
these traditions long established and
enjoyed
the same cannot be said though for the
rights of mothers to go to work
[Music]
this mom suela bravaman is also the
attorney general one of the highest
lawyers in our land and this month marks
a year since her government had to pass
a law just to allow for her to take
maternity leave and to prevent her
having to resign the first cabinet
minister in art history to do so from
your point of view how surreal was that
to have to pass a law to have your baby
and stay in your job it was pretty
surreal you're right it started with a
phone call to the prime minister
which again is pretty crazy i think it's
always a bit daunting for someone in the
workplace thinking about telling their
boss that they're pregnant let alone
telling the prime minister
and when i told the prime minister that
i was expecting a baby in six months he
was incredibly supportive
congratulations great news don't worry
whatever you need will will sort it out
and that was just a huge relief
i was daunted about it and we quickly
discovered that this hadn't happened
before at cabinet level and as a result
there was no provision and i would have
had to resign
if i wanted to have the baby and take
some time off to spend with her
and when we discovered that and prime
minister discovered that we were all
pretty horrified and that's what led to
passing a new act of parliament to
rectify that anomaly barriers broken by
one mother but very different barriers
felt by others at the moment a woman
would need to take an employer
threatening them with patients and
redundancy to a tribunal within three
months of returning to work do you think
the government have done enough in that
area do you think the legislation's
about right we have
protected in our equality legislation
maternity right so that it is unlawful
to dismiss a lady because she's falling
pregnant unfortunately employers are
breaking the law and we do need to
change that culture
jody sims had her first child eight
years ago weeks before she returned from
maternity leave her standing was
promoted without the role initially been
offered to jodie she felt isolated but
lacked the energy and money to fight a
potentially protracted legal battle i
did not have the emotional
strength at that time so it's all well
and good for me to say with hindsight i
wish i pushed against them now that
there's a bit of distance and i've got a
bit more fire in me i didn't have it in
me then
i just didn't i was crying all the time
so
yeah i just had to let it go i guess
you'd like to see better protections and
more security for women when they come
back
absolutely
and preparations underway in this place
to do exactly that
rather than
simply enhancing the tribunal system
that's currently in place what i believe
truly is we should be adopting policies
such as the ones they have in germany
where women are protected from being
made redundant for six months after
they've had a baby
the government now looking at changing
the law to provide further protections
but women in the workplace still
battling beth rigby sky news westminster